[Musique]
pour célébrer ses 30 ans le centre de
musique baroque de versailles a choisi
de faire entendre marc antoine
charpentier compositeur du xviie siècle
moins connu que rameau ou lully faire
redécouvrir le patrimoine musical
français de cette époque c'est le mot
d'ordre de cet établissement créé en
1985 ce qu'il y a 20 ans et il y a même
encore dix ans ne travaillons pas du
tout de la même manière et c'est surtout
cette évolution qui est notable
d'une part la mondialisation c'est à
dire que centre de musique baroque de
versailles aujourd'hui est vraiment le
centre international de musique baroque
de versailles
et puis la deuxième chose c'est bien sûr
les nouvelles technologies le numérique
qui permettent de fonctionner de manière
totalement différente sur la saison 2016
2017 l'établissement a présenté +235
événements en france et à l'étranger de
nombreux concerts et projets artistiques
menées avec la maîtrise du cmbv composé
de 140 chanteur c'est toute
l'originalité du projet de la maîtrise
qui a été conçu en fait par olivier
schneebeli dès son arrivée en 1991
l'idée de construire un choeur écoles
avec des enfants et des adultes pour
s'inspirer de la couleur du choeur de la
chapelle royale d'un centre comme celui
de la musique baroque de versailles
il fait tant pour faire reconnaître
transmettre diffusé recherché
et il ya trente ans la musique baroque
on ne la connaissais pas beaucoup une
institution unique en son genre qui
souhaitent transmettre au plus grand
nombre
le centre travaille actuellement au
projet génération du lit avec des élèves
et habitant de trappes la création d'une
comédie ballet présenté au public à
versailles et attrapes en mai prochain